україна пустила один отитами сау
глобальному яндексі тероризму
чирок біля складу та лондонський інститут
економіки та світу з ще юного прилюдно
не до низу 2015 рік україною діод разу
за єгиптом то лівію
європейська держава екрану і
більше по стежці та вид терору прикладом
Франція на двадцять дев'ятому у містера
Сієна тридцятому
приніс 2014 коли україна вперше путра
плоду глобальних індексу тероризму суду
вася та ще й пофарбувалася в Україні
нас шахраї гості смертей віктора
актив за річки 650 і добрий би знати 300c
пузатих
вона конфлікт шукає будь-яка з ірану
міста про ти ще мінськ 2 людей з
ішида молодості будуть ефективними та
come to this
lg найбільше постраждав avi тероризму і
рак монологу руку там загнуло моє життя
7000 людей близько 12 тисяч пар вона ну
там сталося по тому 2000 ти раків
судну боку повітря тероризму у свиті
10 адже сотки в знаєш і все тісто suite
числа потойбічних інтерактив і з пузоти в
їй тренд тим душі збив усі гривень
терору в крим околицях u23 державах мін
ставши найвищому їх не історії та цит вечерю
забезпечено тенденцію
75 і сотки в устях теракті в
посилити це з них жертв видав ще на
п'ять країн у team ціан означають що
святий без співу та експорту з означають
терор стоянно передач іваном iii одним
з головних інструментів для
кілограми його політичних сценаріїв
при розпаді кордонів тієї зміни влади